traders in Moscow haven't seen movement
like this since the collapse of the
Lehman group five years ago markets have
retreated about ten percent and the
downward pressure continues epica should
all assets are falling that confirms
that macroeconomic factors do not matter
here or an isolated incident in any one
sector the whole market just gave way it
rapidly went down the ruble has also
fallen to all-time lows against the
dollar and the euro the russian central
bank hiked its key lending rate from
five and a half to seven percent trying
to stem the flow of capital leaving the
country the burgeoning crimean crisis
could further damage the already
battered russian economy first on /
daughter desserts for Russia it's a
question of whether this will result in
an economic downturn Russia was intent
on a modernization partnership which it
desperately needs Moscow simply can't
manage it without technological partners
such as Germany that's essentially
what's at stake if you get some
conductive view german retail giant
metro was planning to launch its russian
subsidiary on the stock market and
invest heavily in the country now
insiders believe those plans have been
put on ice